Doctor Strange was there ever when I got back and he gave us this big birthday
hi everyone its charlie we had a whole
bunch of Avengers Endgame deleted
scenes to talk about hopefully you've
had a chance to see the movie by now
it's been out for a couple weeks
based on the box office most of the
planet has probably has seen it so I'll
start with the Iron Man stuff but they
also posted a clip of the Russos talking
about a lot of other big deleted scenes
that they cut out of the movie at the
last minute so I'll include that in the
video too if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
Marvel videos there's a new round of
that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave an Avengers comment
on the video and it should go without
saying that of course there's going to be
way more deleted scenes when they
released the blu-ray later this summer
we don't have a release date for that
yet but yes I am sure that there's going to
be some giant box set with every single
Marvel movie in it at some point the
Russos also talked about some x-men and
Fantastic Four stuff happening in the
future so what I'll do is I'll play the
clip of them talking about all the other
deleted scenes then I'll talk about all
the x-men Fantastic Four stuff so here's
that clip of them you know without ski
Thor vs. buff Thor presumably we did
have that we did actually there was
there was a sequence where they did
couldn't finally confront one another in
Asgard I can't remember exactly why we
moved off of that I mean I think maybe
maybe it was that we were just overly
complicated and then we like the cat
versus cat better but also I think there
we also deferred to you know the story
line between thorns mother was so recen
--nt yeah that we really wanted to run
that was really more a part of Thor's
journey and repair than confronting his
former self right so that's really what
happened there why we floated that
Katherine Lankford what's the the bottom
what happened there was she ever going to be Cassie at some point was that
she was going to well there was a there was an idea that we had yeah that Tony was
going to go into the metaphysical weigh
station that Thanos because remember we're
fan of saw his daughter yes when he
snapped his fingers and that there was
going to be a future version of his
daughter in that weigh station and again
that's Morgan grown up about exactly we
showed it to a test audience and it was
really confused what we realized about
it
we didn't have we didn't feel an
emotional association with his adult the
adult version of his dog right so we
just it wasn't ringing to us and I
resonating with us an emotional level
which is why we moved away from it so
you shot it just yeah I mean the
attention was that his future daughter
because these stones were dealing with
so asthmatic his future daughter forgave
him and and sort of gave him peace
judo the idea felt resident but it just
which is too many ideas right in an
overly complicated movie feely have said
that there was more to that battle that
there was some some more beats to it is
there any any any stuff that you missed
about cutting from that final they're
always more beats to the battle battles
traditionally at this scale and then we
try to pull them down to their essential
elements sometimes when you get in the
attic room start playing around with it
the structure doesn't sustain or you
find a better structure and a better
path through it and some beats you think
are going to work don't works quite as well
as others and then there's um there's
sort of battle fatigue so right we had a
lot of people on that battlefield there
were other including Howard the Duck a
pound there were others I think there
was like a rocket and Groot reunion
moment there might have been a ant-man
the wasp reunion moment but it just
started to feel like an endless series
of reunions yeah where you know there
are future movies coming and those
moments can be had second choice for the
name besides endgame there must have
been well what's gauntlet any gauntlet
for a long time when we when we should
sorry this is not to rapid fire but when
we went to Korea to promote this movie
the representatives from Disney there
came up to us and said um there's
something we need to tell you in in in
the translation of infinity war here in
Korea when Doctor Strange says to Tony
we're in the endgame now the the way we
translated that here was no hope so
we're like oh so I guess so in Korea is
this movie called Avengers no ho his
depressing
but Infinity Gauntlet was the title for
quite a long time obviously
so the russo has dropped a whole bunch
of big bombs during that but obviously
the scene at the beginning of this was a
longer version of the Iron Man
spider-man reunion during the big battle
before Iron Man used the Infinity
Gauntlet they're actually calling his
version of the Infinity Gauntlet the
nano gauntlet they'll be selling that in
stores pretty soon the Russo's talk
about the Lebowski Thor versus dark
world or when he was in Asgard during
the events of that movie they cut that
just because they liked the stuff that
they were doing with Thor's mother more
I agree that was probably more important
for his character during that moment so
it was a good choice but for those that
are asking about Thor stealin the hammer
from that version of Thor Captain
America wound up taking it back when he
took all the Infinity stones back to
where they stole them from so eventually
dark world Thor wound up getting his
hammer back but the thing that really
blew my mind was actually the Katherine
Langford deleted scene so Katherine
Laing Purves rumored to be in the film
everyone wondered who she was playing is
she going to be someone's daughter like a
future version of someone that's part of
the Young Avengers because we have the
adult version of Cassie Lang which was
also a bit of a teaser for future young
avengers stuff happening in the MCU so
it would just make sense that they
include another adult female character
like that she's probably tied to one of
our existing characters but the way they
explain it is that Iron Man snaps his
gauntlet and it takes him into the soul
world of the soul gem just like Thanos
did when he snapped every one last year
an infinity war and it was a way to make
Iron Man feel okay about what he'd just
done because he was very conflicted
about leaving his family like he says
during the film I got my second chance
cap but then obviously Pepper is the one
that compels him to go would you be able
to rest if you did not help everyone it
was also kind of a version of that last
scene that he had with Pepper where
she's like Tony we're going to be okay
you can rest now so there's another way
to send that character off and also give
you an idea about what's going to be
happening with Morgan Stark in the
future because obviously Catherine
Langford is a pretty notable young
actress so it makes sense that they try
to bring her back in a future movie at
some point but if you're wondering about
a future version of Iron Man or even
iron lad showing up because the kid from
Iron Man 3 was in the film he even said
he's like I would love to be a future
version of Iron Man but I'm not
expecting them to do anything like that
anytime soon and remember this version
of Katherine Langford the adult Morgan
Stark is say like 19 years in the future
so that's a long ways off 19 years
from 2023 so we're talking away way off
I think the only way you see her show up
in a Young Avengers movie is if a team
of Young Avengers and present-day
travels to the future and then they
talked to her there
then the Russos talked about the longer
scenes with the bigger characters who
had just come back from being dusted
like rocket and Groot having a reunion
and then just deciding they would cut
that because they could do it during
guardians three like okay there's a lot
of reunions these other characters will
have in their own movies like we don't
need a whole lot of scenes with black
panther or Doctor Strange because they're
both getting sequels that we know about
they've already confirm so they'll pick
up with black panther and they'll
address what happened in Wakanda in the
last five years during the black panther
sequel and the same thing for the Doctor
Strange sequel we don't know exactly
when those movies are going to come out I'm
assuming sometime 2022
but the Disney CEO said they would
reveal their official schedule later the
summer so no worries we wanted to wait
that long to find out there was a much
longer scene that they shot with the
Avengers in the trenches during the
battle where they're talking to each
other about their plan of attack
they said that slowed the battle way
down so they just cut it for time they
might put that on the DVD too but all
the x-men stuff that I mentioned at the
beginning of the video so the writers of
the movie also did a bunch of interviews
talking about stuff that they had to cut
out of the film - they said for a little
while their plan was to use Scarlet
Witch to change reality on a fundamental
level using a House of M twist from the
comics probably one of the biggest x-men
twists and uses of her powers that you
could do she's one of the most powerful
Avengers so it makes sense that they
would think about using her as one of
these big focal points as we all saw
things didn't go down that way so they
could always use that twist in a future
movie I wouldn't be surprised they're
doing the Scarlet Witch envision TV show
but I don't think they're going to do any
House of M stuff during that I think
that'll mostly be them bringing vision
back to life because obviously he was
one of the few missing things during
Avengers endgame so he can be repaired
they can bring him back he'll be just
fine the writers of the movie also did
address fans questions about introducing
x-men and Fantastic Four using some of
the big twists that they used during the
film at the beginning of the movie
rocket talks about Thanos unleashing a
blast of cosmic energy the likes of
which the universe has never seen when
he snapped everyone then they detected
the same energy signature when he used
the gauntlet again to create his planet
and destroy the Infinity stones at the
end of the film it happened for a third
time when Iron Man
knapped his nano gauntlet to get rid of
Thanos and his forces so there been
three giant blasts of cosmic energy in
the universe two of them happening on
planet Earth
within the last five years so people are
like is this going to be the way that they
introduce x-men because just all that
cosmic energy feels like it's going to
have some repercussions the way the
writers explain it is the Kevin Feige
already has the bones of a plan for
introducing x-men and Fantastic Four and
they're like whatever he does it'll be a
big surprise and it won't be in a way
that people expect in spider-man far
from home the trailer that was released
this week establishes that the snaps
ripped a tear and to multiple different
multiverses different universes out
there is it possible then also spread
radiation that created mutants and this
is how we could get the x-men
okay anything's possible but I don't
know whether really whether you'd need
that I mean genetic mutation is genetic
mutations maybe they were already out
there on I do think that whenever Kevin
decides to do x-men or Fantastic Four is
going to be so I just interpreted that
as them saying no that's not us
introducing x-men and Fantastic Four to
the MCU Kevin Feige is going to do
something a little bit different but
it'll still be really really cool so
what will happen is is there's a whole
bunch of other details about the movie
and deleted scenes they've been
revealing the last couple of weeks we
keep learning more and more so I'll just
continue to do videos as we learn about
really cool stuff believe all your
requests in the comments below obviously
the last couple of episodes of Game of
Thrones are happening so I'll be doing
videos for that and then I just did a
trailer video for the Watchmen TV series
that's starting this fall so there's a
whole bunch of stuff coming up later
this year that's going to be really cool so
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see all the videos
when I post them but what'll happen is
I'll leave the giveaway open til I post
my next Marvel video in my Game of Thrones Episode 5
video will post later
tonight while you wait for everything
click here for all those teasers for
Marvel phase 4 during Avengers end game
and click here for all my Avengers
Endgame Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight!